I am baymax I am scanning your
interrogatives we're going to have to
work together hi my name is Chris a
cassette Chris is a professor at the
robotics Institute at Carnegie Mellon
University today I'll be breaking down
cliffs from movies and TV about
artificial intelligence and robotics
again autonomous decision-making for the
classic movie 2001 a Space Odyssey open
the pod bay doors help I'm sorry Dave
I'm afraid I can't do that
so 2001 is a classic robot movie for a
couple reasons it was just way way ahead
of his time for example it made clear
that a robot doesn't have to have a
human-like body it can be anywhere
what's the problem I think you know what
the problem is just as well as I do this
mission is too important for me to allow
you to jeopardize it some people when
listening to how think he actually has
feelings he's gloating a little bit
about he's outfoxed the humans I know
that you and Frank were planning to
disconnect me and I'm afraid that's
something I cannot allow to happen he
may well a bit program with emotions
that makes him a much better helper to
the humans everything we say has some
expression some emotional content
working with a robot would be incredibly
boring if it was just this monotone this
conversation can serve no purpose
anymore goodbye
al al this movie in the book before it
made clear it's not that the robot hates
us the robot was given a mission and it
figured out that the humans were going
to interfere with the mission this
mission is too important for me to allow
you to jeopardize it
I know that you and Frank were planning
to disconnect me and I'm afraid that's
something I cannot allow to happen in
order to achieve the mission the humans
had to go and this is a story that we
see over and over again in talking about
robots decision making Star Wars well
I'm not going that Bank it's much too
lucky this way is much easier what makes
you think there are settlements over
there the term of Star Wars robots is
that they were all quirky and
personalities and it was fun to watch
them unfortunately reality is a lot more
boring what are you talking about robots
first of all wouldn't use sound to talk
to each other so you'd have two robots
standing there and there'd be nothing to
see I've just instead they just transfer
what we call a utility function don't
get technical with me which is something
that says how much are you willing to
pay to get something and if only humans
could do this we would solve a lot of
conflicts and catch you following me
begging to help them because you've limb
to get it social robots Silicon Valley
so you just been out here all night
talking to a robot you know would you
excuse us for a second yes what's been a
huge surprise ever since the beginning
of artificial intelligence is if you get
an artificial intelligence and a human
being one on one you basically can't
stop the hee
from bonding with the robot I know that
Fiona is a man-made piece of digital
equipment powered by artificial
intelligences but I don't remember ever
having a conversation like the one I've
been having with her over the last 12
hours that was shown in a very early
conversational agent in 1960s incredibly
crude called Eliza and people would sit
there they type to it for hours I told
her that I was afraid of being found out
as a fraud and she told me that she's
afraid of magnets I love that line
ripping a part of body doesn't mean the
same thing for a robot as it does for a
human you're not killing the robot the
robot brain could be in the cloud
anywhere and could be connected to
anybody you're just talking to a
microphone and a speaker data collection
ex machina this is where Ava was created
if you knew the trouble I had getting an
AI to read and duplicate facial
expressions I would argue that it's sort
of no tougher to do facial expressions
and any of the other things what's hard
about facial expressions is getting the
decent data you sort of be need to be in
a studio like this to get a good shot of
somebody's face you know how I cracked
it every cell phone just about as a
microphone camera and a means to
transmit data so I turned on every
microphone and camera across the entire
planet
what is absolutely accurate and true
today is if you want to build
intelligence currently the best way to
do it is collect a lot of data and I
mean a lot of data more is better and
use that to train something called
neural networks which are a sort of
crude cartoonish model of how we used to
think the brain work here the app
reminds the crystal ball part is science
fiction there's a weird thing about
search engines there's like striking oil
in the world that had an invented
internal combustion my competitors they
thought that search engines were a map
of what people were thinking but
actually they were a map of how people
were thinking
most people are horrified to hear that
somebody is recording data but look
here's the deal letting people use your
data
hopefully they anonymize it is how we're
gonna get useful service that's exactly
right
cooperation robot and Frank just bring
me some cereal that cereal is full of
unhealthy ingredients I threw it away
they sort of made an extreme version of
you know that cereal is for children eat
your vegetables enjoy this great fruit
to eat this grapefruit your four
children scooping in order to help
people you got to make a bargain with
them
what's the carrot it can't just all be
stick even humans taking care of other
humans have the same problem Frank we're
going to have to work together you are a
robot Butler I'm not a butler Frank I'm
a health care aide a program to monitor
and improve your physical and mental
health
the big problem we're gonna have in the
future where we're building all these
things that are supposed to help us you
know how should they behave if all we're
succeeding is automated nagging nobody's
gonna like it that thing is gonna murder
me in my sleep
healthcare robot big hero six
this is what I've been working at hello
I am baymax your personal healthcare
companion
I cried when I first saw that movie a
robotic nurse some of my own work helped
to inspire baymax hello in order to get
robots that are safe to take care of
people as I wanted to make them very
light looks like a walking marshmallow
no offense
we started looking at inflatable robots
on the theory you can't kill someone
with a pool toy going for a
non-threatening huggable kind of thing
the Disney folks visited our lab and
really developed it in ways we hadn't
even thought out and thus we got a lot
of inspiration from watching that movie
I will scan you now scan complete
you have a slight epidermal abrasion on
your forearm I suggest an antibacterial
spray what's in the spray specifically
the primary ingredient is bacitracin
it's a bummer I'm actually allergic to
that you are not allergic to bacitracin
what we can't get scanned for is the
internal chemistry which it was sort of
suggested that baymax could scan you and
tell you about something that was
chemically wrong with you you do have a
mild allergy to peanuts
but that's within the realm of
possibility and you know might happen in
our lifetimes what kind of battery does
it use lithium ion that's actually a
little problematic
yes Luthi and ion batteries are really
good to use but they're also likely to
explode or burn up and there's this
famous case of NASA and they had a robot
sitting in a lab the robot suddenly
starts burning and basically burns up
entirely
so batteries are gonna be a problem you
have been a good boy have a lollipop
we've seen in other movies that you know
a robot that comes in there and just
tells you what to do it's gonna be met
with a lot of resistance hostility it's
just not gonna work so this is my baymax
it takes care of me I take care of it
you know it does take much for
robot to be a good companion awakening
Avengers age of Ultron you are all from
a global peacekeeping initiative
designed by mr. stark let's just start
there trying to show you a robot what
we'll call booting up from not operating
to fully operate
that's typically a complicated process
where you have a bunch of different
modules or subroutines that turn on one
after another and if you don't get the
sequence right nothing works
peacekeeping program let's just start in
this case they tried to show you lots of
lights and pictures and we turn the
robot on it starts thinking really fast
and within seconds it's figured out if
I'm gonna achieve peace in our time
I've gotta get the humans under control
I've got to be the master of everything
I believe your intentions to be hostile
conversational agents we'd like to ask
you a few basic questions before the
operating system is initiated this will
help create an OS to best fit your needs
how would you describe your relationship
with your mother it's pretty stereotyped
to ask a question about your mother in a
psychological test that's going on in my
life
reaction is psychological tests are
really annoying and they made that one
really annoying thank you please wait as
your individualized operating system is
initiated yes the system doesn't have to
hear your entire response to move on to
the next question a real psychological
test typically involves a lot more
questions what do I play do you have a
name
yes Samantha hey where'd you get that
name from I gave it to myself actually
when did you give it to yourself well
right when you asked me if I had a name
I thought yeah he's right I do need a
name but I wanted to pick a good one so
I wrote a book called how to name your
baby and out of 180,000 names that's the
one I like the best I actually expect to
see this level
of dialogue about restricted subjects
like your email to happen pretty soon
because there's intense economic
pressure for the folks at Amazon to get
a LexA to do it do you want to know how
I work yeah a lot of very smart people
are working really hard on it and I
expect it to happen pretty soon that's
really weird personality Mali a really
interesting question in robotics is
should robots have a personality or
emotion or motivation so far we've been
modeling our robots on Spock totally
logical in terms of making them
successful when they're on their own it
might be the case that we need to give
them personalities emotion motivation in
order to succeed well he's an
interesting example of what we call an
autonomous robot in the movie of course
he's all by himself and he has to figure
out what's interesting Wow and I would
argue that his personality could play a
big role in figuring out what am I gonna
put in my little trailer there and what
am I gonna just leave on the ground and
he discovers this little plant which he
treats with great respect
[Music]
that personality is what guides Wally in
making the big decisions the decisions
that matter consciousness humans I am a
synthetic but I'm awake
conscious I really don't know what to do
with consciousness I certainly think I'm
conscious but I have no idea of any of
you are conscious I have no real way of
finding out whatever is I don't want to
know from an engineering point of view
consciousness is not yet a really useful
concept so when I build robots I never
even think of consciousness I can think
sentence feel okay so a lot of people
wonder you know could robots really feel
can they get in love and all this stuff
and I guess I've been in this business
long enough that from my point of view
if they act like they're in love then
they're in love
I can't tell if someone else loves me I
just have to go on whether they act like
they love me I like you more than
anything I've ever seen or heard or
touched now we certainly can generate
that speech that she gave to RCF
everything Norman is bigger and brighter
when I'm with you you make everything
brighter with your around you make
everything
well I think that that probably comes
straight out of hallmark targeting
chappy
by blowing that stuff up he did two
things one he gave the robot something
else to shoot at or think about try to
get the robots to attack somebody else
so even though they know you're there
you're not important enough
figuring out if a soldier or vehicle is
on your side or an opponent is a hard
problem it's in fact a hard problem for
current military systems with airplanes
and other vehicles we put in electronic
markers that for example respond to
radar and send out a code that says I'm
on your side and if they don't generate
the right code they're not on your side
I don't believe we do that on soldiers
yet but we could so this scene appears
very complicated and hard to process
partly because we're not used to acting
this fast but actual soldiers are
trained for this kind of thing and are
trained to process this very quickly
robots would also be able to process it
very quickly
if you crank through all the
possibilities all the different ways how
to detect humans we probably could find
they hide from the robots but it isn't
gonna be easy small talk from Star Trek
captain great I understand that our
carrier has some very interesting
weather patterns mr. data you all right
yes sir
I am attempting to fill a silent moment
with non relevant conversation small
talk it's hard to tell the difference
between a robot tuning its parameters or
writing entirely new programs one of the
original programming languages lisp was
created so that robots could write
programs for themselves have written you
subroutine for that purpose but if we
say tuning parameters is a form of
writing your own programs robots have
been writing their own programs for a
long time if you really are not
interested in small talk then you should
keep your eye on commander Hutchinson at
the reception this afternoon he's a
master now I want to hear about
everything that happened after you left
Starfleet medical
if you essentially learn how to interact
with people by watching people you're
gonna pick up on their interactive
styles and they're all the things they
do a pleasure the pleasure is mine the
original goal of robotics in the 60s 70s
80s was robots ought to be able to
figure it out for themselves when we
started trying to get robots to do what
humans do we've realized what humans do
isn't dictated by the laws of physics I
was aware of that and the best way to
figure out how to imitate humans is to
directly imitate humans smart cars
Knight Rider
can't you there why would I go night
writer is another classic robot in this
case TV show it's really important and
it sort of guided a lot of thinking of
what robots should be like a little
consideration would be a beginning we
can certainly have robots that fancy
lights on them
it's like Darth Vader's bathroom we can
certainly get cars to talk wave all
machine we could build kit today the
difference between KITT and what we
could build today is KITT is what we
call a I complete it knows about
everything I am scanning your
interrogatives quite satisfactorily the
car we'd built today would be expert on
a very limited number of things I think
it's much more realistic that we're
going to have robots that are pretty
good at a limited number of things and
gradually get better and better I
suppose so
rather than we go instantaneously from
you know toaster level intelligence to
it's as good as a human after all we're
only human right conclusion we watched a
lot of clips a lot of stuff that I saw
40 years ago folks in the studio here
with me weren't even born yet and I have
to say it's made a huge difference to my
life
help me build robots I hope that
watching this will get a lot of young
people inspired to also build robots
it's tremendously creative it's a lot of
fun let's do it